Did you see the green,
the green new deal?
Alexandria causer Cortez?
No,
there's so she publishes.
It's a nonbinding resolution,
which means that even if it passes,
they can't enforce anything,
but my God,
I like the fact sheet.
They released alongside it,
literally said they want to provide economic security for people who are
unwilling to work.
Right.
What?
Unwilling.
Okay.
Really,
I swear to God.
Yeah.
CNBC reported this.
They covered this.
Apparently this got removed from the site.
The reason I bring this up is there's a chart from the ACA,
the economist.
I frequently show this in the content I make where you can see the Conservatives
are coalescing around a common ideologies.
For a while there was some upset in the party because people didn't like Trump,
but now they've pretty much,
you know,
they say it's the party of Trump.
People agree with them.
Ted Cruz even stands and gives them a standing ovation at the state of the
Union.
But the left has been spreading out and again,
this is from a chart put together by the economist.
The Democrats are very clearly being spread from far left to center and it's
kind of making it very difficult for the Democrats to,
you know,
put forth something that makes sense.
If Alexandria Ocozzio Cortez,
you know,
she puts out the green new deal,
but in the bill it talks about equity,
racial justice,
the gender pay gap,
things that have nothing to do with the environment.
And then Nancy Pelosi says it's green dreams,
you know,
and she,
and she derives this,
you can see that there's a new faction of the Democrats that will have,
you know,
holy ideological drive.
And I think one of the reasons for this is what we see on social media,
right?
The,
the ideological bent of the platforms then lead to the mass followings of
specific individuals who then use specific tactics to get elected.
And it's,
you know,
when,
when these platforms only allow certain ideas to form,
those ideas will naturally rise to the top of our political space.
And then you get crazy stuff.
Like,
if you're unwilling to work,
we'll provide you economic security,
which,
you know,
I don't know necessarily what that means other than some people who choose not
to work.
We'll get paid,
I guess from taxpayer money,
but that seems completely insane.
And not only that,
where's that money coming from right from you?
This is actually another funny thing that,
no,
I mean,
let us know what you mean.
Literally.
Yeah.
Andrew is Andrew Cuomo Sad,
God forbid if the rich leave New York because,
uh,
I believe 1% of New York,
the top 1% pay 46% of their,
of their,
uh,
taxes of the revenue they use.
And so they just had a big budget shortfall.
I believe it was,
uh,
something Trump did that caused a short fall in there.
And they were asked if they would tax the rich and he was like,
no,
God forbid,
you know,
they'll leave and they're already leaving.
So I,
I'm,
you know,
incoming,
a million people saying I'm conservative for bringing that up.
But you know,
facts are facts,
I suppose.
Well,
facts are facts,
and that's what's really important about this.
And when you suppress any,
any ideology,
if you are on the left and you suppress the right,
it is just going to shore up their defenses and they're just going to harden
their line.
That's just how it goes.
That's how human natures,
you can't tell people what to do.
You can't.